alors que dans une grande partie de la
france les beaux jours reviennent la
question du respect des gestes barrière
se pose et si pour le moment à un
confinement ou l'avancement d'un
couvre-feu n'est envisagée que
localement le gouvernement a imaginé une
autre solution interdire la consommation
d'alcool sur la voie publique
voilà la solution miracle trouvé par
plusieurs régions l'interdiction qui
vise à éviter ce type de rassemblement
pas de distanciation social pas de
masque par exemple qui à paris dans deux
endroits particulièrement propice aux
regroupements comme place de la
contrescarpe ou huit bus si on était
inquiet même pour rentrer chez nous il
fallait jouer des coudes à certains
moments l'interdiction pour le moment
temporaire et d'une durée de 15 jours
mais qui pourrait être reconduite
les mesures prises également à lyon dans
certaines régions du sud que certains
aimerait voir étendue à toute la france
c'est le dernier atout que le
gouvernement a dans sa manche
alors faut-il interdire la vente
d'alcool pour freiner l'épidémie et
merci d'accueillir ce soir marcel
bénézet président des bars et brasseries
et propriétaire d'un bar également merci
d'être là à voir seule chose est déjà
aux rats voilà tout va bien vous êtes en
petite forme en ce moment en souffrance
face aux souffrances barre et on avec
nous pas loin de sélectionner
stigmatiser c'est pendant parler dans un
instant et on a un grand docteur un
addictologue docteur laurent karila
merci d'être là le remercie c'est la
première fois que vous venez je suis
très heureux de vous rencontrer de vous
inviter parce que c'est un pote donc
merci à lui d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation et j'embrasse simone sa maman
voilà qui doit nous regarder alors c'est
vrai que c'est tombé
et pour vous c'est un drame marcel
bénézet 7,7
surtout que nous aussi on est déjà dans
une douleur insupportable parce que nous
sommes fermés 2009 ça va faire une année
que ce virus est arrivé et assurer la
france la france l'europe et que nos
établissements sont fermés depuis le 16
mars l'année dernière et que nous avons
des fermetures d ouverture aujourd'hui à
20 petits moyens de faire un peu
d'argent pour arriver à payer le loyer
c'est ça certains bars parce que très
peu en réalité c'est très bien justement
c'est peut-être là le problème c'est
qu'il ya très peu qui font de la vente à
emporter mais par contre on ne consomme
pas à consommer sur place vous prenez
votre mère vous allez le conditionner sa
course à sept nouveaux simat mais le
problème aujourd'hui voilà c'est ça
c'est le problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a rompu
on a fait rue debussy contrescarpe mais
ils vont aller rue de seine ils vont
aller rue de l'ancienne comédie
ils vont aller dans les rues adjacentes
l'avait place des conserveurs la
contrescarpe alors on parle un petit peu
de ce qui se passe voilà donc dans
certaines raisons parce que ça va être
interdite
certains jours juste on le voit un pour
freiner l'épidémie faut-il interdire la
vente d'alcool
là il n'y a que des non il n'y a que
deux oui j'aimerais qu'on ait un nom
d'abord de nicolas pernikoff pourquoi
tout simplement parce que on sait bien
que les rassemblements c'est une
catastrophe donc il faut pas il faut
effectivement continuer à à bandes de
l'alcool à emporter mais il faut
interdire le rassemblement et c'est vrai
que les gens ne respectent pas ça ce qui
me fait qu'on s'est retrouvé avec une
foule immense vous voyez aujourd'hui par
exemple mais donc faux de faux mais oui
mais oui alors il donc si oui alors
faut-il interdire l'alcool
oui interdire l'alcool la motive mais là
rien il n'a pas compris c'est dans l'été
dans les bars c'est ce que venait dire
monsieur bénézet oui ils appellent donc
quand moi je vois que à noël par exemple
moi je prends pas d'alcool je prends des
cafés ce qu'on interdit c'est
l'important j'ai signalé à ben oui parce
que l'interdît c'est le stationnement
mois à noël quand j'ai commencé qu'à
consommer debout devant le marais mounir
non vous devez marcher ça eh bien oui
mais bon maintenant il y voit là c'est
qu'il y avait des attroupements joie
c'est ça qui a fait qu'il est par israël
la décision ou éméché chaque oui mais ça
qui a fait que les autres il a déçu
guillaume jean claude que c'est une
utopie de penser que parce qu'il est une
interdiction d'alcool les gens vont
arrêter de boire et voir accorder sur
les radios sur la grille sont ils vont
réussir à s'en procurer et puis pardon
tout l'une se fussent tout le monde est
choqué de ces images de relâchement mais
souvenez vous il ya un an
mars avril 2020 il y avait le
confinement il y avait les mêmes images
les gens n'y avait même pas de masque à
l'époque les gens qui dansaient dans la
rue les marchés qui étaient bondées de
ses terres dont je comprends pas
pourquoi tout le monde s'excite ya un an
il y avait les mêmes images et les
chiffres baisser donc faut se calmer
laurent karila l'addictologue du coin
vous êtes d'accord avec cette enseigne à
une étude il ya une étude écossaise qui
a été publié il ya pas très longtemps
qui montre que l'alcool consommé dans
les bars justement entraîne des
désordres désintoxication alcoolique
aiguë et on ne gère plus les gestes
barrières on ne gère plus rien on est
complètement désinhibé c'est un vrai
vrai problème non mais c'est ça en fait
le problème c'est ça le problème c'est
ça le vrai problème c'est pas c'est pas
exactement c'est que quand on est sous
l'emprise de l'alcool ce que voulait
dire on compte leur chien au new
plymouth faire les gestes barrières et
c'est ça qui pose problème c'est ça qui
pose problème c'est ça qui contamine
tout le monde en fait d'accord on voit
bien c'est que il ya des petites
terrasses de café qui ont ouvert pour
juste du click and collect sur des café
le matin on voit il ya un an
mort de jean yanne attroupement de gens
qui et si on a un qui est malade dedans
eh ben c'est terminé mais oloron je sais
que vous êtes voilà vous me comprenez
aussi la détresse complètement de voie
là de deux seulement de ces gens qui
possèdent des barques et qui maintenant
ça nous permettait de payer le loyer ça
nous permettait d'arrondir un peu les
angles parce qu'il souffre depuis des
mois et des mois
voilà il le sait un monsieur b né il
était déjà venu nous voir ils étaient
déjà en détresse il ya pas mal de temps
et là c'est encore pire et c'est ça le
promets je sais que vous êtes très
conscient je reconnais d'arrivée par
l'ambiance et addictologue je parle en
tant qu addictologue mention comme en
tant que père de famille a surtout c'est
il ya un vrai problème de régulation des
choses et les barmans les bistrotiers
les restaurateurs ne peuvent pas réguler
la consommation de leurs de leurs
clients ainsi si vous c'est en open bar
alcool il va avoir des désordres y voir
des désordres de désinhibition
intoxication alcoolique et nuits
d'ivresse sur la voie publique quoi et
après il ya cause de contamination il
faut faire comme en israël comme ce qui
va être prévus en israël est pas de
forbach sinal sais que ça va aller ça
hurle vaccinale ceux qui sont vaccinées
peuvent se retrouver en l'installant
avec respect déjà regardé je vois tous
les téléspectateurs derrière un qui sont
derrière qui font comme ça derrière vous
qu'ils font dans ça pour eux c'est pas
une bonne idée on en a déjà oui mais il
faut il faut une réalité de terrain il
faut une réalité terrain là actuellement
on ne peut pas sans le bac ça on ne peut
rien faire contre cette épidémie on a
des gestes des mesures de réduction des
risques comme les gestes barrières comme
faire attention comme met son mac se
laver les mains et c'est ça c'est des
mesures de réduction des risques mais ça
ne suffit plus moi je mets tout à
l'heure à l'hôpital j'ai trois aides
soignantes qui sont contaminés alors que
tout est nickel
ça continue et les variants sont tous là
gilles verdez voudra oui à vous êtes
d'accord où il faut totalement moi je
pense que on n'en est plus à tergiverser
il ya couvre-feu et bien pendant toute
la période du couvre-feu moi je serais
pour interdire totalement la vente
d'alcool en france
alors je sais on va me dire mais
l'alcool en france ça fait travailler
des gens oui mais là il faut réagir et
c'est vrai que les beaux jours arrivent
on va se rassembler et doit on consomme
où on fait des fêtes on interdirait là
on interdit dans quelques rues mais il
faudra interdire sur tout le territoire
ce il ya des hommes et leur siège et
près des écoles ont passé le
des cafés des résidents mais près des
écoles on peut pas boire dans les stades
et gymnases donc arrêté aujourd'hui
interdite au cc ça fait rire interdit
rue du bus si mary contrescarpe parce
que le monde nous regarde on est dans la
france entière donc c'est bien de sentir
aujourd'hui la vente d'alcool mais c'est
pas dans les bistrots le problème c'est
que les gens l'achètent dans les
supermarchés dans les épiceries dans les
supérettes vont rentrer chez eux avec ça
mais ça va être pire que le bistrot
parce que si c'est un hic c'est que ça
va être pire mais oui on peut pas
interdire les choses c'est pas possible
on la politique pro démissionner ça
marche jamais sa marge mais on l'a vu
pour le cannabis la marche jamais donc
le truc c'est pour l'alcool
on va pas interdire la vente d'alcool
les sujets qui sont malades de l'alcool
vous n'avez pas leur interdire de boire
de l'alcool c'est hyper compliqué cette
question la vraie question c'est comment
se raisonner comment réguler les choses
moi je crois qu'il faut marteler les
gens et de la politique de prévention
plus tôt faites gaffe quoi bon d'y aller
qu'est ce que ça va pénaliser encore un
truc comme ça ça va pénaliser les bons
citoyens qui m'ont petit bois vous
modérément et qui ont envie de boire un
verre le week-end entre amis s'ils sont
2,4
enfin moi je comprends pas à un moment
donné on va encore pénaliser les gens
qui ont des agissements normaux pour
ceux qui font des réunions et des
réunions comme ça à ce moment là on
punit les réunions mais on n'interdit
pas l'alcool aux gens jean-michel moi je
suis d'accord avec est libre pour
justifier une telle mesure on monte
toujours les mêmes images des quais de
seine des rue de la soif dans les
différentes villes de france ont
évidemment il est rassemblement de
jeunes mais en fait moi je vis dans mon
quartier il ya plein petit café où les
gens respect qu'ils boivent un petit
verre de vin comme ça ils respectent les
mesures ils boivent ils remettent le
masque après il n'y a pas de débordement
de gens bourrés que ce n'était pas bon
dieu te pénaliser tout le monde pour
quelques débordements sépare de ses
passages de monterfil en fait il faut
que les gens se responsabilisent pas que
l'état responsable et jean faut que les
gens se responsabilisent puisque chaque
comportement additionner ça fait ça peut
faire une nouvelle vague mais je le dis
est pénalisé mais voilà notre docteur
c'est que quand on est sous l'emprise de
l'alcool
on est contre moi c'est de
responsabiliser un verre mais pas plus
pourquoi pénaliser le secteur des bars
de l'alcool et ou qui sont déjà assez
attend déjà visée depuis un an
évidemment c'est chacun pour être
solidaire pour sortir de ça chacun doit
faire à prendre conscience de son
comportement
vous rappelez il faut appeler une mesure
importante c'est il ya des
recommandations pour l'alcool c'est 2
r pas plus par jour et pas plus de dix
verres par semaine je vous faire deux
jours sans alcool comme ça c'est des
recommandations de base pour tout le
monde
coville ou paco vide donc c'est vraiment
important de redire oui vous êtes vous
dit tout haut niveau daniel oui parce
que moi je pense qu on en crève des
demi-mesures il fait et personne n'est
gagnant je suis je suis consciente des
problèmes de ceux qui vendent de
l'alcool mais si on fait tout le temps
d'aider des demi-mesures on n'y arrivera
pas donc il faut vraiment prendre
voilà une des mesures qui ne font
plaisir à personne mais qui sont très
très fortes et peut-être qu'on arrivera
à s'en sortir parce que voilà moi j'aime
pas ça par la prohibition je suis sympa
ça va être galère suis désolé mais la
désinhibition ça va être étendu à toute
la france bien entendu très
prochainement je pense à monsieur
bénéficie on ouvrait tous les bars wee
man extérieurs tous parents je dis tout
ça j'aurais le problème c'est que il ya
une petite quantité qui font de la vente
à emporter
donc si on ouvrait tous les bars on les
oublie ça ferait une fluidité et parce
que quand vous voyez quand vous prenez
dans paris qu'un gorille ce désastre
économique de ces établissements seront
fermés demain imaginer qu'ils sont
ouverts avec tout ce tout ce genre tous
et toutes ces personnes personnes
divisées dans tout l'est pas ce serait
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui le problème
c'est se ramasse dans dans un espace
restreint
et alors que s'il y avait le boulevard
saint germain tous les bars étaient
ouverts tout serait allé le problème se
ramasser un endroit précis il veut citer
des rues marcel bénézet c'est un kit de
paris
sur la rue mouffetard stars s'amusent à
muri général de gaulle y avait il ya des
amis café dans la poche
je suis déjà l'établissement dans le sud
aussi vous donner l'adresse ip tenir
qu'est ce que tu vas venir les gens
psychologiquement dans cette situation
terrible c'est d'avoir l'impression
qu'on avance dans le combat contre le
virus ou le confinement de mars 2001 il
a été traumatisant pour tout le monde et
là on nous sort de nouvelles
interdictions qui avait pas à l'époque
on peut plus commander à manger après
21h30 dans certaines grandes villes on
peut plus acheter de l'alcool alors
qu'au premier confinement qui était le
plus strict on pouvait en acheter dans
les supermarchés dans les commerces etc
au chaud que psychologiquement mais
c'est terriblement n'avait de nouvelles
restrictions à la consommation
mais non bien sûr de lave le vrai
problème est moins évidemment on peut
pas demander aux français maintenant
alors après tout ce qu'ils ont vécu en
plus de pas s'acheter une bouteille de
vin ou bénigne ou peu importe c'est à
consommer sans modération mais ce qu'il
faut interdire évidemment c'est la
consommation sur la voie publique exact
mais bizarrement à l'éphédrine ans il
faut laisser les gens aller dans un bar
voir un petit bassin pas mes 6 ans il a
un bon vin ou peu importe qu'on puisse
le vendre il faut consommer
tranquillement chez soi on va pas
maintenant que gâcher effectivement en
ce qu'ils sont là ils font quoi ils
fondent apéro à 30 ans n'a pas de sens
soyons sérieux deux minutes et là il
faut arrêter de prendre pour des cons et
là où c'est encore et les gens doivent
être énervé parce qu'une fois plus qu
ils ont mis quoi on fait pas les
restaurants fermés baron fonds vers les
terrasses et on le fait encore mieux
boire comme ça c'est débile
ces composés débile at élisons la
consommation dans la rue et rapide
problème voilà vous êtes d'accord je le
prends comme assistant signale la colère
à écouter mais que je suis pas toujours
tenter d'aplanir les importantes il faut
dire que cette épidémie a fait augmenter
les troubles psychiatriques et
addictologie qu'alcool et ses symboles
de plus de 25%
vous savez chez elle est la substance
j'ai explosé sur cette année c'est même
pas l'alcool c'est la cocaïne c'est pour
vous dire le vrai problème de cette
épidémie et qu'il faut prévenir et
guérir et soigner les gens c'est bien
vous soyez la cia il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont mentalement très atteint web
rassure pas par par cette épidémie
bien sûr est-ce que vous ayez de plus en
plus de cas de dépression a augmenté de
+ 25 % les rênes des épisodes de stress
post traumatique c'est l'équivalent de
gens qui ont vécu les attentats c'est
pour vous dire est que les gens qui
vivent des attentats ce qui peut vivre
comme traumatisme ébats avec l'épidémie
confinement il ya + 30 % et c'est une
donnée internationale s'est même pas
nationale dans notre profession c'est le
cas moi j'ai moi le moi j'ai les
adhérents les patrons de cafés de
restaurants m'appelle
ils sont désespérés parce qu ils ont un
blocage pur pour toucher leur là là là
le fonds de solidarité ils ont bloqué un
sujet telles subventions
ils sont aujourd'hui ils sont ils n'en
peuvent plus je vous assure que moi j'ai
déjà quelques courses ont dû mettre la
clé sous la porte à 200% moi je vous
assure que sans la france c'est un
croissante % des établissements ne
rouvrons pas après après le canton trois
jours énorme se rendra compte dans dira
tienne cela paraît ouvert celui là pas
réouvert j'ai vu là parce que c'est un
énorme à notre profession
bien souvent c'est des gens qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie dans un
établissement qui ont mis des gérants
c'est à dire que ce sont des jeunes qui
ont repris hausse en partie en province
ce jeune il est parti il a donné les
clés mais pour le reprendre la personne
là aujourd'hui vous aurez percée qui va
reprendre un établissement de bar de
restauration avec des contraintes vous
avez aujourd'hui vous avez des
fermetures administratives qui vous
tombe comme ça on vous faire mieux comme
ça sans rien vous demandez mais moi j'ai
des gens qui m'appellent misson aux
larmes c'est des gens qui sont
désespérés
aujourd'hui la profession on se rend pas
compte on a trois piliers on a le ona le
sanitaire certaines pourtant on a le
canal l'économique et on a surtout le
psychologique
aujourd'hui on est rentré dans la phase
psychologique des gens c'est dramatique
aujourd'hui on va sortir de ce pauvre
fracassé pascal improvise on aura trouvé
la solution il faut se faire vacciner au
maximum un couple allez vous faire
vacciner
la seule c'est le seul moyen de pouvoir
sortir mais après ça va les problèmes
psychologiques ont pensé téléspectateurs
oui à 32% voyez nous à 68%
voilà ils sont de votre côté puisqu'ils
sont donc c'est un petit peu la
proportion qu'il y avait ici jaune